[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to another video this one
is all about what life has been like
with luca so it's actually been over a
month now he's five weeks old so we're
gonna take you around the house and show
you our systems and how we've been
managing and adjusting to having luca at
home
[Music]
and grab the camera so here we have the
diaper changing table it was gifted by
our neighbors thank you ryan and louie
how many times has he peed on his face
so far
like three times already
so yeah this is where i spend
my nights when i change his diaper and
it's cool because this thing has like a
little light so i have a pacifier in
four areas of the house well one of them
is in his diaper bag
but the other
three
there's one here
so whenever he gets fussy
there's one there there's another one
over here this area we have is bassinet
which i pushed close to my side of the
bed there's a pacifier there white noise
machine another this is a burp cloth
we have this
swaddle a swaddle blanket but also like
the swaddle thing like a swaddle swaddle
a swaddle sack i think they call it oh
the best moments of luca over this whole
month of having him here it's definitely
seeing him smile like he smiles so much
like he's such a happy baby and i know
in the first few weeks or whatever it's
mainly like reflexes like he's not
intentionally trying to smile and even
more so now like he smiles a lot and he
even laughs a lot like he'll be sleeping
and he'll just start cracking up and
it's so freaking cute
[Music]
those are definitely my most favorite
moments and just bonding with him really
because i i am so lucky and i get to
spend my entire day with him like
literally attached to him the whole day
i get to just smell him and kiss him and
feel him and hug him and just be with
him and i'm so attached to him that like
i need to be mindful to not hog him up
because casey will want to come in and
like snuggle with him too and i'm like
okay here and he's like peeling him away
from me i'm like no i have to share
like we both made him well so we have
this lounger thing so he doesn't have a
flat head trying to have him sleep on
that and i have another washcloth here
there's always a washcloth here
because this is where we sleep i sleep
and then where i breastfeed sometimes
because i'll use my pregnancy pillow as
a nursing pillow sometimes very smart um
and then over here is another station
you actually have a nursing pillow
nursing pillow here another washcloth
that stays here the pumping station here
and yeah marker to mark for the breast
milk stuff and once i empty out breast
milk into a bag then i store it in this
refrigerator i don't pump anymore
but the first few weeks when we were
here i was pumping a lot we were still
struggling with latching on so
i was pumping and like this refrigerator
filled up like three times like three or
four times yeah now it's all in the
freezer downstairs yeah in the garage
and we're thinking about selling breast
milk so if you know anyone that needs
breast milk we got plenty of it yeah
we're not selling breast milk okay fine
in the beginning i was really
considering it see see
that was producing so much
but now i like my body matches his needs
now so
i don't have an excess amount of milk
and then it's so stressful sometimes
because we spent a lot of time trying to
feed and then the whole hour after him
eating is like spent trying to burp him
and like trying to get all that air out
and then next thing you know once that
whole hour has passed and i'm like okay
i think he's good let me lay him down
now he can probably go to sleep then
he's hungry again so then the whole
cycle starts all over again it's like
feeding and then burping and then
feeding and then burping and you gotta
throw in diaper changes in there
sometimes so i feel like it's around the
clock non-stop tending to him but it's
fun it's been really fun
i'm honestly having a really good time
even though it's really tiring i'm like
i wouldn't want to be doing anything
else right now but anyway back to the
station so here we have casey's computer
chair which
is gold this thing's been here for so
long now that i've totally forgot that
that was mine this is the lucas sitting
chair yeah so i wanted to get an actual
like lighter or like an actual rocking
chair but this space is so small and we
don't have any room here
so instead we decided to bring the
computer chair here and i got this thing
called a ready rocker which is really
cool because it's a portable rocking
device where you can literally just lean
back and you get to use any
any surface as
a rocking chair so this whole dresser
thing here is all filled with lucas
stuff so this is all like his three to
six month old clothes
bibs and bigger socks and like bigger
swaddle swaddle sacks and stuff and then
over here it's all his preemie clothes
that he no longer fits in so right now
he's been wearing newborn stuff but it
still fits him a little bit big but
that's good yeah room to grow so this is
his dresser and then over here i laid
out all of this this is lucas corner
yeah and then over here i laid out all
the books so i've been trying to read to
him every day and he's still like
looking past things like he can't focus
on anything yet but
okay
oh and then back over here on the diaper
changing table i want to show you how i
organize there so this basket has his
the clothes that he's currently wearing
so i organized it by like onesies pants
uh footies socks mittens beanies which
he's never i never put a beanie on him
but he has them and then in here the
rest of the diapers that we currently
have down here
are these uh
these pads
for their changing table pads yeah
and then swaddle blankets
over here is like more sheets these are
actually crib sheets so we can't use
them yet because this crib hasn't came
in yet and then over here is like
more wipes
i have nursing pads so these are my
diapers
for my boobs
some lifestyle wipes more wipes i
learned i learned that lysol wife aren't
baby wipes not the same thing
yeah i had to teach him
when i was pregnant so thank god it
wasn't well luca was here and then if we
move over here bathroom area
so
this is like the bottle washing station
so this is dish soap and then the bottle
thingy and then the drying rack whenever
i pump i have to wash all the things
so i wash them here so that's super
handy julia gifted us this
julia
along with some other stuff and then
over here
we have
this basket that i haven't found a use
for yet but i'm planning on filling it
with supplies and putting it in your in
your car okay whenever like we start
going out more because right now we're
just at home a lot
so we have that and then this to bathe
like we don't really use that we
actually use this one yeah oh this is
not part of the tub this is just well we
do use this though so we fill this up
with the water and then
it's actually a two-person job to give
him a bath so casey's constantly pouring
the water from this bucket onto luca
while he's laying in the stuff taking a
shower bath yeah that's really what it
is it's not really a bath yeah and we
put the tub on the counter up here i'm
like washing him with the soap and the
washcloth making sure he's clean but
it's funny because you can see the poop
stain already
it's yellow oh yeah
there was this one day where i had to
leave luca for the first time i left for
like three hours i had to go to an
orthodontist appointment where they put
more stuff on my teeth i also had to go
to oh a postpartum appointment to go see
my midwife the whole time i'm like are
we done are we done i need to get back
to my baby i need to get back so i'm
like i definitely have some sort of uh
postpartum anxiety for sure because i'm
pretty attached to luca and i'd have had
like weird scenarios play in my head
where i'm like did he stop breathing or
like you know like anxiety for sure but
with isaac man postpartum anxiety was
through the roof like way worse so at
least i know i'm not
that bad you got experience on your side
now yeah i know like with isaac i had to
put him in a bouncer in the bathroom
with me and i had to watch him every two
seconds like as soon as the shower doors
start fogging up i had to wipe it
immediately and check and like stare and
making sure that he was breathing
because for some reason in my head i'm
like he's gonna stop breathing and he's
gonna die on me or something like it was
bad with isaac would luka i have it a
little bit but it is helpful that that
have casey i'm like okay cool calm down
it's not just me
casey is also helping like
we're both keeping him alive learning
how to change diapers learning how to
bathe him learning how to feed him
learning how to comfort him learning how
to put him to sleep all these skills
it's all new to me i feel like i'm so
lucky to have tiff because she went
through all this already and so she i
feel like i'm being taught by a veteran
in the game and so it's not as daunting
i guess ironically it's been really
eye-opening to i guess how we all come
into this world like as a son i'm like
oh this is this is what my parents had
to go through and
it has made me appreciate my parents
more it's weird the first month of
having luca has made me maybe a more
insightful son
to my parents hey say hi to everybody
okay
i will have to say farewell to this
office
soon yeah well not yet because you're
still using it so this is handy whenever
like i'm taking a shower whenever i'm
doing something where i'm like oh casey
can't hold luca can you watch him so
he'll put him here as he's working on
his stuff true and as you notice i only
have one chair now i have to
take it back and forth between the two
desks is i have my
my work desk and then my my personal
well this is actually tiff's desk but
this is now my personal computer here
and my work computer over there and i
toggle back and forth so the challenge
is with luca it's been mainly around
feeding you know initially it was
because i didn't have my milk and he
wasn't really latching on and then we
found out that he actually was tongue
and lip tied so you see that frenulum
it's
all the way straight down his gum so
this thing
in here it's like connected all the way
down to like the bottom of his gum which
means like he couldn't really stick out
his tongue very much and his lip
couldn't like open like it's supposed to
like go over my nipple in order to
really latch and he couldn't like his
his lip was like really stuck to his gum
line and so
when he was two weeks old we took him to
a dentist that my midwife recommended
and he got a procedure done in order to
release his tongue in his lip and that
was oh my god that was so heartbreaking
here i'm crying they have me in this
room can't be
i can't be in there with him
[Music]
they said it would be about 10 minutes
so 10 minutes of torture and so he was
just
wailing and i had to hear him cry as he
was going through this procedure because
what they did is they got a laser to
like cut and like release that
muscle and so
that was really rough and then right
after you know they say like 25 or
something of moms they'll report that
immediately after latching because after
that procedure you have to latch on the
baby to see like how the breastfeeding
goes and they say like immediately you
can feel the difference and like the
pain goes away because it was
breastfeeding was really painful at that
point and that's why we decided to go
through the procedure and for me like i
did feel a difference but it wasn't like
oh my god this was so worth it kind of
difference like i still felt pain he was
still having issues latching on not
until about like two weeks after the
procedure like around this time now that
he's over a month now we're okay like
now he's latching on pretty well but
it's still a little bit painful for me
and we can't figure out why exactly we
tried using a nipple shield that did not
work it was still painful it actually
made it hurt more which i don't know how
that happens but nibble shield did not
work and he's also been doing this thing
where he swallows a lot of air like he's
just constantly swallowing air he does
this thing where he has my nipple in his
mouth and he's eating but he's pushing
my breast away with his hand and he's
like pulling away with his
head he's chomping hard on my nipple
like so hard where it's so painful and
i'm trying to like detach him and so
like finally he'll detach himself and
when he does he's like frantically
trying to get the nibble back in his
mouth because he's so hungry so it's
like this weird like back and forth and
i'm like why are you doing this why is
this happening and so it's still been
challenging but at least we don't
struggle that hard with
latching but
he's biting a lot and my midwife
recommended like you know as soon as he
starts biting remove the breast so he
learns to not do that
cancer give me attention yeah they
totally
they want to eat
you got
yeah 20 minutes can you wait 20 minutes
and then we have this rocker here that
we have on top of the dining table
because this is where zucca hangs out
when we're all eating
or just whenever we're downstairs like
you come
washing the dishes or just doing some
part of the kitchen
i'll put in here another washcloth and
this is where i have the other pacifier
i'm like we're ready all over the house
great mom
great mom we have this high chicken just
for decoration because he's not invited
drew it's more of like a glimpse into
the future makes us happy seeing like oh
potential
he's gonna be there one day he does
occupy like a quarter at the table now
though we don't have the same
room
okay all right sorry it is your quarter
of the table you know he's like why are
you complaining dad
this is gonna be my spot anyway
[Music]
all right and then down here we have
this other basket where there's a whole
bunch of diapers washcloths wipes more
cream
this nipple cream and then this thingy
for boogers that we got from the
hospital so i keep this here
but
we also got
a package
from our p.o box thank you
to those of you that have sent us stuff
because there were
gifts for the baby that i already picked
up before
we didn't vlog it
but this most recent package so i'll go
with the letter first this one was so
sweet so this is from tammy
from georgia look she's so freaking cute
she's like i cannot wait to see baby
chances before we announced they were
born they're so lucky to have wonderful
parents like you and a great older
brother wish i could help them but i'm a
broke college student good luck on your
baby journey but she took the time to
write us this super strength
letter i freaking love it thank you so
much tammy for taking the time to write
to us i loved it so sweet this other
package is also there's a
there's a note here and this is from ink
valley designs
and they're saying that they have this
etsy shop that's called ink valley
designs they actually made it so michael
karen and their baby bellamy they
created these things for us which i'm
like oh my god this is so sweet so look
[Music]
they get this
this is before luca was announced but
look oh that's cool
isn't that so cool that's really cool
because of the spoon it says baby oh
that's classy
freaking does this bowl stick to the
bottom yes oh gosh
that's so cool i want one of these and
look look look
a straw a tiny little cup with a straw
yeah ask me all yours it was so freaking
thoughtful
and then look this
gifted us
casey
and then
tiff thank you so much michael and karen
and bellamy if you guys want to check
out their etsy shop go to at inc valley
designs they also have an instagram
thank you guys i'm actually going to
order another one for isaac
i have one too oh maybe
isn't that so sweet of them
cutie
[Music]
you